so let me let me mention a couple of
people in terms of successful years
there and there are many many many more
there are many more successful leaders
and there are robber barons if you will
or you know or imperial bankers grabbing
the gussto for themselves at the cost of
social contribution and good so let me
just mention a couple one is Milton
Hershey the man who founded the candy
company really created the market for
milk chocolate right at the turn of the
century astoundingly interesting and
commercially imaginative businessman
marketer you know very much an inventor
always always playing and tinkering with
food recipes particularly sweets so he
built a brilliant business much bigger
than he ever imagined and then he
decided that he wanted to create a new
kind of social compact between workers
and his factory workers and his
corporation and he created in Hershey
Pennsylvania which was really a kind of
grand enormous ly expensive although he
didn't regard this he gave all he gave
away all his fortune by the time he was
40 had kid tithed away giving away
everything there was nothing left except
a house for him to live in he it was
enormous ly expensive experiment in
creating a social utopia and he did that
and you know at the time he there were
you know had lots and lots of critics
but the bottom line was that people that
worked for Hershey and people that lived
in the town lived a very different kind
of life through the years of the Great
Depression and well beyond than many
other workers and if you travel to
Hershey Pennsylvania today I've spent a
lot of time there reading his letters it
you know his impact was extremely
important there's an enormous my civic
pride there there's an enormous amount
of you know historical knowledge and
sense of place and the importance of the
past and great great optimism about you
know the spirit of the place and what it
can achieve so that's a very interesting
example of someone who placed some big
bets on the social footprint of his
business characteristics
Henry huh excuse me the characteristics
of Milton Hershey were we're
generalizable I think a great business
sense a big big big lens on the world so
unlike some business leaders who really
understood how to get their particular
laundry out her she's always looking
very broadly there's a kind of
anthropologists and sociologists as much
as he is a candy maker and being counter
very comfortable moving between the high
and the low right the the the individual
consumer the individual work or the
taste of the chocolate right in the big
picture of what's going to happen to the
candy marker what's gonna happen in the
Great Depression what does that mean for
what I need to be doing in my town and
in my business great ability to move
seamlessly between high and low and no
sense no pretense that somehow all he
should be doing is strategy in the big
picture now understanding that being a
successful leader is often very much
about details and being completely in
the details at moment and I think
thirdly he just had a great sense of
empathy for people that's so critical
empathy it's so critical to be able to
in a moment's notice put yourself in the
shoes of another person be it an
employee or a competitor or your partner
or your family or business Lee a
government leader trying to influence
great empathy just you know a real
engine of empathy so that's so Milton
Hershey is is a good example I think
someone who I can't get away from I just
can't get away from as an amazing leader
a successful leader a person with a
great sense of fiduciary if you will and
responsibility and stewardship is Oprah
Winfrey I mean we think of her as this
great celebrity and you know the
newspapers and social networking and you
know all the media just had a field day
a couple of weeks ago when she said
something down for my show in a couple
of years but but there was very little
mention of Winfrey as a leader and think
about about how powerful her wake is
think about how powerful the waves are
that she travels on in terms
of lapping up on the shores of many many
people's lives and think of how careful
she is in wielding that power and I
think about her candor her savvy
business sense I spent I spent about
three years writing cases on her for the
Harvard Business School because I
thought the Harvard Business School
needed to really take a close look at
this woman and how good a businesswoman
and entrepreneur she is so she has this
great sense of the business and the
brand and her audience and what to say
no to she has an extraordinary
forbearance but she's also you know
again funny and warm great sense of
empathy and big you know always looking
at what's going on in the world and and
you know just very very non-judgmental
in terms of you know what she'll talk
about or what's a fair game for her
influence or you know what what what
might happen next a very a great
openness so I think that she's an
astounding example of a shining star of
leadership right now and we need her we
near because she's about light and
making ourselves better and the higher
road and understanding that business is
about both the left side of the brain
and the right side of the brain and
really really thinking deeply about
about the authority that she has an in a
time when we see so many people in the
public stage just dropping this ball the
responsibility that goes with that power
a great sense of that responsibility and
how to use that in a way that makes the
world a better place for people that
aren't you know her employees or aren't
for bankers or aren't for family you
know really a really big positive spirit
they are with a great sense of
stewardship so Oprah Winfrey and then
you know I think I've just finished
another case that it took me it took me
another year or two I had these long
slow pregnancies on bono so you know
part of that was I've always had a big
crush on him
still do but but that wasn't the really
that wasn't the driving rationale
certainly not good enough rationale for
creating a year-long Enterprise writing
a case about him for the Harvard
Business School but I thought that the
story of the band u2 as a business
needed to be told because it's a story
of fellowship as well as branding as
well as positioning as well as
strategical sustainable defensible
differentiation as well as adaptability
and suppleness because their music and
their distribution and their game has
changed a lot without ever seeming to
abandon the core tenets of what makes
you - to you - so I thought that was a
great story but then I thought the way
that he although all the lads from
Dublin but particularly Bono is the
spokesperson in the front person how
they have used the power of music and
the and that new you know influence of
global media particularly social
networking and music distribution to
really send a larger and bigger message
about our sense of obligation to others
about places where there there are
people that that aren't spoken for and
that don't have much power and then to
think about how he could educate himself
on all of the things he needed to know
to make a difference in two areas that
he decided to make a difference in a
third world debt in Africa and and and
antiretroviral AIDS drugs in Africa and
then you know sort of spend a couple of
years on a mission of learning really
educating himself and then to figure out
how to become a politician and a
spokesperson and a Salesman right
because the organisation that he and
Bobby Shriver founded called red it's a
fascinating organization that they had
to then go sell themselves with to lots
of companies and to do that all with a
sense of humility and not to mention you
know the great music I just thought that
that was a very interesting example of
leadership today and there and he and
Winfrey are interesting because they're
great businesspeople although we don't
talk in the massage their fantastic
entrepreneurs but they are individuals
that people of all ages from all nations
around the world perceived to be
leaders who are not for sale and boy oh
boy do we need those kind of beacons
right now